où étiez vous le 12 janvier 2010 pour ma
part
totalement pour les jeux olympiques de
vancouver en effet j'avais été
sélectionné comme médecin d'urgence pour
travailler au village olympique des
athlètes à vancouver même peut-être que
le fait d'avoir travaillé pendant trois
ans par grandeur dans des conditions
extrêmes par des graves quoi se préparer
bien à de tels types d'événements
pourtant cette journée-là la terre
entière fut frappée d'une terrible
nouvelle
le tremblement terre en haïti 7 sur
l'échelle de richter
trois cent mille morts 300 mille blessés
1.2 million de personnes sans abri
quatre millions de personnes déplacées
la terre venait de trembler haïti haïti
venait d'être secoué plusieurs types
d'émotions sont traversés déchirement
tristesse angoisse je recevais multiples
courriels des sms d' alerte et j'ai reçu
un appel de mon ami sylvain médecin à la
croix rouge canadienne qui me
demandaient à ce que tu peux venir nous
aider évidemment que j'ai dit oui mais
je ne pouvais pas quitter tout de suite
mais aussitôt qu'un deuxième appel à
l'aide provenant de la poche canadienne
pour l'épidémie de choléra qui sévit cgt
du premier vol vers port au prince
arrivés sur les lieux les mots me
manquent pour décrire ce que mes yeux
voyait instabilité insécurité désastres
désordre inconnu
arrivés sur les lieux nous étions
cloîtré au niveau 2b scanne le cas base
de la fédération de la croix rouge parle
à plusieurs jours pendant lequel les
communautés souffrent et à tous les
jours on répertoriait les événements
hijacking kidnapping vol vandalisme
meurtre tout était inscrit sur une carte
à tous les jours on faisait le décompte
on ne pouvait pas quitter
nous étions vraiment cloîtrés et nous
pouvions pas aider ces communautés
malgré tout
par une matinée ensoleillée très tôt
nous avons décidé d'aller braver la
tempête et non de nous installer à
carrefour dans les périphéries de port
au prince
carrefour est une ville qui a été
détruite à 40% après le tremblement
terre et qui expérimentait l'épidémie
une des plus sévères en haïti entame de
choléra vingt quatre heures après être
arrivée sur les lieux
nous avions installé nos tentes et nous
étions prêts et nous avons reçu notre
première patiente est ni une jeune fille
de cinq ans qui souffraient de
déshydratation sévère
quand vous savez le choléra est une
maladie entérique qui déshydrate et peut
même tuer une personne en bonne santé en
dans le quelques heures annie a quitté
notre nos installations notre centre de
traitement du choléra
trois jours après l'arrivée en bonne
santé bien rétablie trois semaines plus
tard 1000 patients après après plusieurs
nuits blanches avec l'aide de plusieurs
collègues médecins haïtiens dévoué nous
avions accompli ce qu'on espérait c'est
à dire de bâtir le meilleur centre de
traitement de choléra en haïti
nous étions parmi les plus performants à
la fin de ma mission
la croix rouge canadienne m'a demandé de
décrire en résumé pour transférer en
fait l'expérience que j'ai vécue à mon
collègue qui venait me remplacer mais
comment décrire ce que nous on a vécu
pendant les trois semaines et qui nous
préparait en fait pour planifier la
réponse d'urgence pendant les semaines
qui allait suivre
comment partager cette expérience et
comment décrire les conditions des 80
patients qu'on recevait à tous les jours
en fait les seules informations qu'ont
récolté était sur des bouts de papiers
qui étaient imbibés de clore le matériel
qu'ils ont utilisés pour désinfecter
pour la prévention des infections à mon
retour à montréal je me suis posé la
question quoi faire pour transmettre
autant d'informations et il était
évident à mes yeux qu'il fallait
utiliser les nouvelles technologies
tel que vous le voyez sur la carte
les nouvelles technologies sont
omniprésentes dans le monde ici la carte
reproduit l'utilisation de la
technologie d'internet en fait
2.7 milliards de personnes se connectent
à internet à tous les jours soit 40% de
la population de la planète
il ya autour de 7 milliards de
téléphones cellulaires en fait de
connexion cellulaire ce qui ne ce nombre
dépasse le nombre de personnes vivant
même sur notre planète à ce que c'est
cette technologie qu'il fallait utiliser
on n'était pas si sûr quand vous voyez
sur le graphique
la technologie n'est pas équitablement
répartis la technologie est beaucoup
plus présente dans les pays développés
que les pays en voie de développement
c'est ce qu'on appelle la fracture
numérique céline équité en termes
d'accès à l'information entre les pays
développés et les pays en voie de
développement
de plus les pays en voie de
développement ont des fast food ou qui
sont fragiles en haïti après le
tremblement terre plus de 90% des
infrastructures cellulaires était
détruite
donc on pouvait pas les utiliser c'est
non fonctionnel en plus ces pays là
malheureusement subissent des
catastrophes
année après année les environs entre 200
et 500 catastrophes naturelles qui
survient dans le monde est à peu près
cinq cent cinquante conflit actifs et
entre 300 millions et 500 millions sont
touchées annuellement
ce n'était donc pas les technologies
d'aujourd'hui les technologies usuelles
qu'on pouvait utiliser pour les réponses
d'urgence
il fallait innover fallait inventer une
nouvelle technologie qui pouvait
permettre aux équipes de réponse
d'urgence de répondre à ses besoins en
tout temps en tout lieu qui devait
abordable et calment et être mobile pour
être déployé dans les pays en voie
développement
c'est là que nous avons une vision de
créer cette technologie que nous avons
appelée humanité 3d j'ai dû retourner
sur les bancs d'école
parce que pour concrétiser un tel rêve
il fallait se ressourcer après deux ans
programme de mba hec montréal mcgill et
sert montréal après avoir rencontré des
gens formidables qui m'ont inspiré
avoir collaboré nous étions sûrs de
pouvoir y arriver nous avions les
capacités de produits et de réaliser ce
rêve
c'est ce que nous avons fait nous avons
créé une technologie unique
en fait ce que nous avons crié c'est une
application cette application s'installe
sur les téléphones cellulaires
même quand qu'internet n'est pas
disponible
même quand les réseaux cellulaires sont
détruits l'application permet à un
téléphone de communiquer avec un autre
téléphone et 1,3 un téléphone et ainsi
permettre à des équipes d'urgence de
collaborer ensemble on a rajouté des
outils dans cette application qui permet
aussi aux équipes d'urgence de mieux
planifier leurs réponses d'urgence une
gestion des tâches de la messagerie et
de la cartographie 3d en temps réel et
c'est là où nous utilisons également les
drones pour pouvoir nous aider
la technologie est là pour aider les
équipes d'urgence à sauver des vies
parce que la technologie permet aux
équipes d'urgence aide à ces communautés
d'être mieux préparés d'avoir une
meilleure réponse d'urgence est
également d'avoir un meilleur
rétablissement dans les communautés la
technologie permet d'aller solliciter
les drones pour aller chercher des
images et on reconstruit l'ensemble du
monde en 3d en temps réel
cette cartographie est utile pour les
zones sinistrées
parce que l'environnement change au fur
et à mesure des parlements des désastres
nous avons même poussé la technologie et
nous travaillons aujourd'hui à insérer
cette technologie sur les drones
directement pour permettre à ces
appareils de collaborer entre eux ainsi
ces appareils peuvent communiquer entre
eux partager des messages partagés des
cartes partager également des messages d
alerte qui permettent d'éviter des
collisions dans les pays en voie de
développement après un désastre ces
technologies peuvent aider les équipes
d'urgence à sauver davantage de vies
nous avons été récompensés par grand
challenges canada pour cette innovation
humanitaire en fait nous avons été citée
comme une innovation qui veut
transformer le domaine humanitaire
nous avons eu plusieurs partenaires qui
nous ont appuyés qui nous appuient
toujours actuellement nous sommes en
semi finale pour le concours cisco le
grand talent cisco nous avons été
sélectionnés avec 14 autres équipes
parmi 3000 soumissions provenant de 100
pays
cisco et l'organisation de l'entreprise
qui fabrique 80% des installations qui
servent à nous connecter sur internet
mon histoire s'est déroulée en quatre
temps tout d'abord cette expérience
inoubliable et unique que j'ai vécu en
haïti
ensuite ce rêve
cette vision qui me dépasse et qui nous
dépasse et qu'il fallait concrétiser
troisièmement le retour obligé sur les
bancs de l'université
même après plusieurs années d'école et
quatrièmement la collaboration
l'entr'aide la passion des gens
formidables qui nous ont aidés à
réaliser ce projet pour aider l'humanité
j'espère que j'avais mon histoire vous
avoir sensibilisé à quelques éléments
premièrement le besoin en fait d'être
entrepreneur également le besoin de
devoir se ressourcer parfois après
plusieurs années d'études sur les bancs
d'école
enfin ce besoin de garder cet humanisme
en nous que nous aide un peu à nous
surpasser à innover même dans les
moments les plus difficiles
même dans les endroits les plus austères
merci pour votre écoute